CAPITOL HILL INVOLVING HOUSE
REPUBLICANS, THEIR EFFORT TO
STRENGTHEN FOOD STAMP WORK
REQUIREMENTS, AND THE PUSH TO
RESOLVE LINGERING ISSUES OVER
IMMIGRATION.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL
TONIGHT ON THE TACTICS IN THE
STRATEGY.
>> Reporter: THERE COULD NOT
BE A BETTER TIME TO TAKE ACTION
TO HELP MORE PEOPLE JOIN OUR
WORKFORCE.
>> PART OF THE HOUSE SPEAKER'S
PITCH FOR SUPPORT OF A FIVE-YEAR
FARMVILLE EXTENSION.
BUT AS G.O.P. LEADERS TRY TO
ROUND UP THE FINAL VOTES TO PASS
IT, DOWNSTREAM CAUCUSES TRYING
TO FLEX SOME MUSCLE ON
IMMIGRATION IN EXCHANGE FOR
SUPPORT ON THE FARM BILL.
>> THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
MEMBERS BELIEVE WE SHOULD HAVE A
VOTE ON IMMIGRATION BEFORE WE
HAVE A VOTE ON THE FARM BILL.
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO CONVINCE ANY
OF OUR MEMBERS TO GO FROM NO TO
YES ON THE FARM BILL.
SO WE WILL HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS TONIGHT WITH
LEADERSHIP.
AT THIS POINT, THERE IS NO DEAL
TO BE MADE.
>> Reporter: THIS COMES AS A
MODERATE HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE
TRYING TO FORCE RYAN'S HAND ON
AN IMMIGRATION BILL BY BEING
WILLING TO WORK WITH DEMOCRATS.
AT LEAST 20 REPUBLICANS HAVE
SIGNED ON TO THE SO CARGO
DISCHARGE PETITION AND RYAN HAS
TRIED TO HOLD HIM OFF BY SAYING
HE WANTS AN IMMIGRATION PLAN
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD BE
WILLING TO SIGN.
>> WE WANT TO SEE IF WE CAN DO
OUR OWN IMMIGRATION BILL, SO
EVEN LABORING TO GET NUMBER 218,
IT'S CLEAR WE DON'T HAVE THAT AS
A BILL.
>> NANCY PELOSI CALLED THE
ACTION VERY BEAUTIFUL.
>> RANK AND FILE, AND EVEN
REALLY MORE ESTABLISHING THOSE
MEMBERS THAT HAVE IN THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN SIDE
HAVE COME TOGETHER ON A
BIPARTISAN BILL, THAT THEY HAVE
CONSTRUCTED, THAT THEY HAVE
GAINED SUPPORT FOR, AND THAT
THEY HAVE NOW MADE PART OF THE
DISCHARGE PETITION.
>> CONSERVATIVES ARE NOT AMUSED
BY MODERATES MAKING THIS PLAY AT
OUR SIGNALING WHAT THEY WANT.
THE IDEA OF BEING SOMETHING
CLOSE TO A SECURITY FIRST PLAN
OFFERED BY JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN,
BOB GOODLAD.
>> THE FIX IS WE HAVE TO KEEP
COMPROMISING AND FIND THE SWEET
SPOT THAT WILL PASS INTO LAW.
>> FOX HAS LEARNED THAT G.O.P.
LEADERS PLAN TO OFFER THE
FREEDOM OF CAUCUS DATE NEXT
MONTH'S FOR THAT CONSERVATIVE
BILL.
IF THE FREEDOM CAUCUS DOESN'T
TAKE IT, LEADERSHIP COULD PULL